so thank you very much for taking the
time on a Sunday and you're all
attending this conference here special
thanks to be organizers sponsors and all
the other speakers for such a wonderful
event today so today's talk is on object
detection to instant segmentation before
I get there a quick introduction about
myself I am based in Warsaw I work for
linga row I'm part of the data science
team in ring guru Seoul in Cairo is
headquartered in war so we have our
offices also in Philippines and and
United States so what do we do in our
company so we build different kinds of
solutions for our customers mainly
focused in harnessing the power of data
for them so whether it is building
business intelligence systems or whether
it is building advanced analytical
capabilities or building chatbots for
them or leveraging the big data platform
IOT so it's it's pretty much the entire
spectrum so we do a lot of projects but
the cool part is on leveraging data for
the customers and building advanced
capabilities for them so in the next
half an hour what are we going to be
talking about is in the basically the
realm of computer vision so we are going
to be focusing on the various algorithms
that have gotten involved from the
fundamentals of like the object
detection systems to the later ones in
the instant segmentation space so we and
I will probably spend some more time or
focusing on one of the instance SiC
mentation algorithm which is mask our
CNN because I am coming from a
consulting background so my emphasis is
on ok how do I take the technology or
all the research and the advanced
developments that have happened taking
it to building solutions for the
customer so how what are all the kind of
scenarios can be envisioned what's the
what's the value that we can bring
through these solutions to our customers
so I will touch upon that as well as end
with ok the some of the challenges that
we are
dealing with even in the even after the
advances in all these computer vision
algorithms when we are actually
implementing it and how some of the
latest researches are hopefully they are
they are they are going to solve those
problems as well and we will wrap it up
with a with the Q&A so it's going to be
a packed next half an hour and so this
is for people who are already familiar
with this it's you you would have seen
this picture multiple times but just to
get the context for for some of people
who are not spending their their day job
or their time in the university on
computer vision tasks this this just
paints the picture of the various
terminologies that we will be using
during the next half an hour so what is
classification is something as simple as
okay what object are we seeing in this
picture whether it's a video or whether
it's a image identifying the object that
that is there in the picture so that's
the classification part detection or
it's also you also will see the
terminology of object localization is
nothing but where is this object in the
image so it's the position of the object
that is seen this here here it is
basically around finding the coordinates
as as to okay so this is the bounding
box this is where the object is present
segmentation looks at it slightly
differently here we are looking at it
pixel wise what is the pixel wise
classification of each and every object
so it has this pixel belong to a
background or does this pixel belong to
an object of object in this case in this
example it says is this pixel belongs to
a balloon or whatever it might be
instant segmentation takes it a level
further here it is again pixel based
classification but at the same time you
are trying to identify the instances of
the objects separately so in this in
this picture you will see multiple
balloons but each of those are actually
identified as okay this is number one
number two number three of this
particular object so all of this
actually it is taking us one step
towards understanding the what we are
what we are seeing so in increasing the
visual interpret a polity of of of the
algorithm so that's that's the gradual
progress
for for in all of this and each of this
will cater towards solving different
kinds of problems that we have not not
like instant segmentation is needed for
all of the problems that there are
scenarios it's only it's only enough to
know what the object is where the object
is the masks are not necessarily an
important but in other scenarios you
don't need a much more detailed level of
visual interpretation so the family of
algorithms that we will be going through
in this the first half of this session
is starting from our CNN so our CNN is
the first of the the several algorithms
that came up which basically identifies
what are all the objects that are
available it's basically it's like
finding the object proposals from from
the image so if this it is it does using
a separate algorithm which is not part
of this architectures the first it goes
through that algorithm called selective
search finds the objects of interest and
then for each of those objects there is
a separate convolutional neural network
layer which is trying to identify and
class and a classifier sitting on top of
it which identifies what this object is
as well as you are trying to run it
through another bounding box regressor
to identify the location of the object
in the image so as you can see if you
have your selective search is configured
and in a way that let's say it generates
thousands of object proposals you will
have to run a neural network for each of
those object proposals separately to
idle to finally get what you are trying
to identify from the image so obviously
not the most efficient one so the second
one is fast our CNN and the dinner the
other the second advanced version of the
model here there is still the selective
search which is doing the first round of
finding the object proposals but then
the convolutional neural network as
opposed to our CNN is not done for every
proposal separately it the conversation
work is run on the entire image so
basically you are not trying to learn
the same feature spaces like I mean all
the features for a particular object of
interest which are mostly going to be
overlapped so you are your proposals are
all overlap in the initial phase but
that can be optimized when you are
running the convolutional neural network
all in one go there by your and and on
top of that you are we are doing the
same thing second so there is a bounding
box regressor which is sitting on top of
it as well as you are trying to have you
that's the that's the objective of this
algorithm anyways you anyway need the
classifier to work as well as the
bounding box regressor to know where the
object is present in a particular image
but it's one step forward that there is
there is it's definitely much faster
than the are CNN the next one which is
still relevant in in in many of the
papers that you read now also even in
masks are CNN you would find that faster
our CNN still is very much used in all
of these algorithms they are all of
these architectures so how does fast our
CNN differ from the earlier versions so
there is no selective search algorithm
which is there so there is which which
means that the first thing that happens
when the when when when you train this
model is the CNN is first run to extract
all the features for this image and then
so this this network is called as a
regional propose network how it does is
it goes through the image and I will go
about the details of it throughs through
this thing with anchor boxes which are
overlaid on the features and it trains
to identify what are all the regions of
interest in this particular image and
which are then again classified and then
you are finding the objects the position
of the objects so if you look at it
there are four pieces that this this
network is training on first is there is
an RPN layer which is again which is
training on the bounding box
regression as well as as well as there
is the classifications layer which is
finding out whether there is an object
in this position or not so what did what
the RPN does not do RPN is not trying to
actually classify the object our peon is
only trying to make its a light network
so it's not trying to understand exactly
it's not training on whether there is a
particular object like okay this is
there a cat or a dog all that it tries
to do is probably what is the
probability that in this area this
feature is getting mapped to an object
or not so that's that's what RP and s
and the bounding box regression is again
not that is there's not that much weight
edge given to this regression loss at
this stage so as long as there is enough
of the bounding boxes that that we are
we have that we are able to find the
second layer when when the actual
network is finishing our CNN's final
layer is when the classification and the
regression bounding boxes are are
fine-tuned so the for loss function the
loss function typically will have these
four components the RP ends
classification allows the regression
loss and the final fire the final layers
classification and regression loss okay
Yolo is part of a different family of
algorithms it's not it it works very
different than the our CNN family so
what Yolo does another algorithm which
is also focused in object detection so
it needs to identify the object as well
as it needs to find the bounding boxes
for the object but Yolo does not go
through object proposals at all so it's
it's thus it does everything in one shot
so it's like Yolo stands for you only
look once so it's it's not like there is
first layer which which finds the
objects and it's not going to classify
it at the second layer so it's it is all
happening in one go how it does it so
it's it's there is an the input image
you you can imagine an image and then
having a grid overlaid on it so there is
in this example if you see there is a 13
by 13 grid that the initial image is
overlaid with and each of those grid now
will be will have to be having multiple
anchor boxes now anchor boxes are
something like they are they're
basically rectangular boxes you can say
which is which is some are lengthwise to
identify objects which are vertically
position and some are on the widths with
rise to identify objects which are
horizontally position and with different
aspect ratio so you can have something
which is 2 is to 1 1 is to 1 which will
be a square so you have anchor boxes of
multiple aspect ratios and sizes which
are overlaid on each of these grid so
what do you get is a bunch of grid
basically so your your you will generate
bounding boxes of so 13 by 13 times 5
which is like you generate 845 bounding
boxes not all of those boxes are going
to be classified as something with an
object or something with an with with
accurate object localized outputs so
ultimately you will end up with 13 by 13
by 125 dimension output where 125 is for
each of those five anchor boxes each
each anchor box will have an 25 I mean
this is for an example where you will
have an object with 20 classes if your
data set has 20 classes now all of this
dimensions and everything is only with
respect to with respect to the
particular data set so if your data set
has 50 classes then all of these
dimensions will will get updated
accordingly so so the intuition that I'm
trying to convey here is after it goes
through this cycle once and and and the
neural network is trained you are able
to identify it without going through the
object proposal side multiple times okay
Yolo had again it had multiple versions
as well there is a Yolo and there is
yellow 9000 Yolo version 3 and the 2
stage detectors are the family of the
first
faster CNN there is SSDs and other
neural network which I have not touched
upon in this talk which is also very
similar for for the purpose of object
detection so if we look at how these
networks have performed the general
perception is Yolo is fast and the
family of our cnn's the fast faster are
CNN's are slow because of the fact that
it has to go through this layer multiple
times but Yolo has not you know and now
the second perception is Yolo is not as
accurate as the faster RCL ends because
Yolo does not deal well with object
which are smaller sizes if the aspect
ratios are different and and all those
sorts of challenges then I am exactly
Not sure the latest improvements in Yolo
version 3 but this data as per the paper
says that the Yolo version 3 which is
with the different kinds of backbone
architecture is has comparable output
when it comes to when it comes to
accuracy with comparing with faster are
CNN so it's it might not so this Yolo
version 3 which comes as close to fast
at our CNN might not be as far as fast
also because it is probably running with
a with a much larger backbone network so
we were spending time talking about
various algorithms in the object
detection space now we will talk about
algorithms in the instance segmentation
so this is if we implement instant
segmentation with with any of the videos
you can find a lot of people have
interests in this space and you can find
that this is how the the the whole
instance the instant segmentation when
you implement on your data the output
could be like this so a quick
run-through with masks our CNN which is
one of the famous implementations for
implementing
instance segmentation it basically
combines two of the architectures that
that that were already existing the
first one is the fasted or CNN so up to
the time when you have to identify the
object of classify the object as well as
finding the bounding box for the object
it is the faster or CNN in itself they
have made some modifications to it but
the fundamental architecture still
remains the same the second piece where
you are generating the mask mask
detection that part is actually using
the fully convolution neural network so
the FCN so FCN if you would have come
across an FCN model i think i think i am
covering it in the next section okay so
basically masks our CNN has four pieces
of it first is you anyway need to
understand and generate the features so
you will have to run a convolution
neural network to get all the convert
all the information in the in the
feature space so what network is used in
the original paper is ResNet 101 but
there later implementations of it and
the open source implementation uses
other other networks using feature
pyramid network and and other networks
which which have constantly increased
improving on the performance standpoint
so this is like a general idea of how
like a nice visualization you can say
for how a convolution neural network
runs to learn the features that at
different levels so you get the earlier
features are just learning the edges and
and then and then the later features
learn the higher level things so masks
are seen and the first piece goes
through to get the neural network
features generated the second part is to
generate the regional proposal so the
regional proposals are on the feature
space the anchor boxes are overlaid for
different sizes and the output is you
know where the bounding boxes are as
well as the the the class classification
whether there is an object or not the
ROI classifier on bounding box regressor
so this is where the
skaar CNN varies from the standard
faster our CNN is when the feature maps
are remapped to the fixed size so so
whenever you have to classify an image
the one of the conditions becomes this
your your input becomes there there is a
necessity that the input has a fixed
dimension so in order to get it to a
fixed dimension from so after running
the convolution neural network when the
in the feature space each of the
bounding boxes are of different sizes
the dimensions are different so from
this side different size dimensions the
the neural they have to be matched to
the fixed fixed size before it goes
through the classification layer so this
is where the original paper used ROI
pool which ROI pool is basically your
your your you are approximating it by
not only not necessarily approximating
there is there is some kind of
information loss in that so you are you
are only cropping off the the actual
downsized one but the but the rest of
the things information is lost as
opposed to ROI aligned where there is a
bilinear interpolation that is done to
total to to not to have enough to have
enough accuracy vent and unreduced the
amount of loss so this apparently has
significantly improved the performance
when with the bounding box generation
also so not only for the object
detection not only for the mask
generation the ROI aline has improved
the performance even in the bounding box
detection so this is the last part which
is the mask branch which works very
similar to how a segment semantic
segmentation model works so the neural
network is downsized and then it is
again up sized I mean basically it's up
sampled and and there is an one-to-one
mapping between your input and the SEM
and the segmentation masks that are
generated so if your class has if you
are creating the masks for 20 classes in
your data set then your output will be
whatever the input dimension is with the
with with 20 equivalent outputs of that
so this is a nice visualization to
understand what is
filling in the somatic segmentation
space so basically it's it's down
sampled and then and then it is again
feature wise up sampled okay so for my
loss function standpoint masks are seen
and deals with all the loss functions
that the architecture trained with in
the faster our CN n plus an additional
loss functions with respect to the mask
we mask the mask head basically so this
is again pixel wise you will have to map
it with the ground truth and what the
mask is generating and then and and then
that's the the entire loss is actually a
weighted sum of all of the losses so the
reason it's it's weighted sum is you
want to you want to prioritize a
classification loss like penalize the
classification loss higher than the
regression loss so that's that's
possible in this case and or the other
scenario is let's say our CNN loss has
to be much more the penalized than okay
it's okay that you miss something during
the RPN or or or vice versa because if
RP n does not even give you the
proposals right then it's highly likely
that our CNN has nothing to work with so
it's it's up to the implementation to
fine-tune these aspects okay so coming
to the scenarios where we can week where
we can apply so it's nothing new we all
know that computer vision has impacted
in multiple industries it has whether it
deals with medical emerging medical
imaging sports analytics because when
you when when the soccer season is going
right now you see so many
implementations of Mark Sima the mask
our CNN wherein wherein the the the
player positions are detected and then
some kind of analysis getting done so
where we are trying to position it from
our customer standpoint is in in the
field of retail space also so we we are
trying to create prototypes and
scenarios for planograms planograms like
how the shelf space things get
organized and different scenarios so
some of without going like into specific
details so we we look at scenarios where
retail can be improved or some some kind
of things in the manufacturing can be
improved using any one of these
techniques so one of the points which
you would notice here is human post
estimation so masks are CNN actually can
be changed with a slight modification to
to detect the human post detection also
so there's the Facebook research paper
and this where everything else that you
see in this paper and in this picture
remains the same so you have the ARP and
layer you have a detection head you have
the segmentation head which is all the
same so all that is added new is the
keypoint head so it's like if you are
building an application for human key
point detection with 16 or 17 parameters
that you have then if your data set is
created for that then there is a
separate part of the architecture that
has to be changed for training on those
key points there are applications with
dense human pose detection and other
things again it's it's all comes under
the same family of algorithms so if we
have to take this algorithm and and our
the architecture and then go ahead and
apply on our own business case or our
own use cases is first thing is you need
to generate datasets with with those
masks which is important so tools like
label me there is a vo TT this V is V GG
image & notation I think it stands for
so these are all the tools there is
little bit of getting used to playing
around with these tools to to load the
images of for your business needs or for
your other other papers and other things
so you will have to create the masks and
these masks are actually sometimes in
JSON output sometimes the PNG outputs
and then there are there are tools if in
order to use the current implementation
that is out which is open sourced
that is it sometimes the data has to be
converted into the Coco style data so
there is the respite Coco tools which
can be used to convert it as well and
what happens is bounding boxes is not
necessarily needed from the data so it's
the masks is important because you want
to augment the masks for different sizes
so you don't want to use the fixed
bounding boxes and masks then whenever
you are we are we are changing the
orientation of the masks and creating
other other augmented data for masks
then the bounding boxes have to be
generated also so if there is a way to
generate the bounding box from the masks
that is helpful and then you have to go
ahead and then go through the training
and then then and see how it performs
for your data if data has to be pre
processed and those those sorts of
things remain the same cocoa has masks
only for 80 classes so if you have
objects which are very very different
than what the cocoa has and you still
want to do it then your underlying the
base bone architecture for the neural
network probably has to be retrained if
your if your objects that your training
are very similar to what is there in
cocoa then at least at least the
baseborn can be used and the further
layers have to be trained as on top of
that so very good implementation of
masks are CNN in this link I will post
the slider in the slack channel after
the talk
so so how did I go through with this
thing I just followed whatever was there
in the open-source model as well as the
blog post which which said how I can use
it for the sample data sets so it's it's
pretty straightforward for a basic
scenario but when we have to implement
it for different kinds of images which
the positions are different it does not
fare that well you still miss out on a
lot of masks masks which are overlaid on
top of each other so we are still
dealing with the challenges on on this
so this is just an older chart for the
performance comparisons and so for
people who are interested in this room
for taking it further there are there
are very very good implementations for
this which which can be used to leverage
for further understanding and okay so
latest research papers are for this in
this space is issues with qu the the
current mask our CNN works well for the
objects that it is trained for so what
about the background so if you have
images like like liquid sky and other
kinds of things it's it does not so it's
like the the in cocoa there is this
terminology with with objects and stuff
or something like that so it's like
objects the stuff is anything which is
not an object so that that that is seen
there it does not deal very well with
identifying that so the paper learning
to segment everything is is from the
same authors who have done the masks are
CNN so we'll have to I will have to try
it out if if data generation and mass
generation challenges are deal dealt
with better in this and that's it from
from my talk and if we have time I could
just show the code for
so basically this is the open source
implementation for the for the balloon
data set which is which is a new data
set that's derived from which which
which is which is created so all that
you have to do is you'll have to create
similar to this balloon data sets you
will have to create find out images for
your needs and then go through the
labeling part and after that this the if
you look at the configuration now this
is all the things that you will be you
we will have to play around with one is
the the various aspects with the
background the non-match suppression
threshold which which also changes the
output differently so what is non-mac
suppression is when we are identifying
the region of interest or when you're
identifying bounding boxes with with
with the objects there are there are lot
of times the bounding boxes are
overlapping and showing the same set of
features so not much suppression
threshold will actually remove those so
those those were those highly overlapped
scenarios so this is how the the the
masks the once the data is generated and
and and you are able to visualize on the
data this is how the visualization part
of it works and after the after the
training it is
so this is the initial set of bounding
boxes the region of interest refinement
and and and and finally this is this is
how the things are generated so if I can
open up for further questions and thank
you very much
[Applause]
thanks for the interesting talk
I just have one question in your slide
in masks our CNN loss function I saw
that the performance of softmax slower
than sigmoid now to my knowledge softmax
is usually performs well on multiple
object detection at least in CNN so I'm
just curious do you know why sigmoid
could perform better in this case than
softmax thank you yeah so I am not
exactly sure but but what it's what it's
generating here the masks are generated
per class so if I think I think because
of the way the the segmentation the
pixel by segmentation is happening on a
per class basis that's that's just my
understanding that it generates masks
for every so there are let's say you
have 20 objects at this level the it
generates the masks for 20 objects
separately so when we are doing the the
the the pixel wise mapping between the
masks and and and the ground truth
probably the the pleading it asks us as
a single class classification at each
level probably it's it's it's it's
better than better than treating it as
as as a multi class three thing what
into single class sorry the the output
masks so considering that each of the
output class is you are training the
neural network to predict one of the
classes at each point separately so that
that that creates that probably gets the
the the accuracy better I will I have a
link there I will probably have to go
and check on on that why why from where
I took it on on why
exactly it is better okay thanks
hi thank you for the interesting talk I
just have a question if you have any
experience from your work on how
fine-grained is this algorithm like how
can it perform or not dogs and cats and
balloons but for example something very
small I cannot think now about but like
neither or something okay we are we are
trying to do it let's say in the the the
cartons of milk and those sorts of
things so that's that that's the size of
objects that we are dealing with and and
what we are trying to do as part of this
thing is we are trying to build like a
pipeline okay of getting the images
getting the masks trying to leverage the
existing algorithmic architecture and
then seeing how how we are able to
sustain with the result so we are trying
to build the pipeline now and building
like a prototype for such objects now
whether whether it performs for a really
tiny objects or where or something like
identifying a nucleus of thing right
there is there is a data science a
challenge that happens for identifying
the nucleus in an image now for those
sorts of things I guess I guess we are
not exactly sure but for an object of a
certain size we are seeing that yeah
because of the fact that they they are
still in the same aspect ratio in the
dimension of a person standing or some
things it's it's still okay but not not
disagreeing that for for when the sizes
and the dimensions changes now the whole
thing knows this is quite quite a
different thing altogether yeah
I I was all knowing about for those
instant segmentation more or less how
many did I need to train on do you need
much more data for instance segmentation
and for object detection for specific
scenarios or for no no no I actually for
uh we are we are trying to generate as
much data as we can for the for our for
our kind of objects that we are dealing
with we are not training the backbone
network so we are still expecting that
for the kind of objects that we are
dealing with we are we are expecting
that that the features can be learned
even with the existing backbone but for
the objects that we are we are trying to
ultimately classify and generate masks
for we are generating a lot of data for
that thank you thank you thank you
[Applause]